so i want to give you a warning before
you watch this this is probably the most
uncomfortable interview i've ever done
in my life and i've interviewed a lot of
different people
uh i want to warn you you may not want
to watch this video because the stories
this moderator tells of what his job was
at facebook with the videos he was
watching every day and his job was to
report to facebook to take these videos
down and many of these videos were left
up
they're going to leave an uh a a an
image in your in your head so if you
don't want that kind of a thing just
don't watch this now on the flip side of
it
this was scheduled to be released a
couple weeks from now and it's being
released today because
of today while you're watching a video
today today is decent october 4th
and uh
facebook's been down for the last few
hours all day facebook and instagram
have been down
and
i i don't know what this has to do with
that if anything
i just think it's something you need to
watch to know because this stuff bothers
me a lot because this kind of stuff is
stuff that innocent kids are being
affected by
and i think the people at facebook can
do something about this so if you watch
this
and uh you feel compelled to share it
with others who have influence
uh i recommend you do that but if you're
somebody that doesn't have
uh uh or doesn't want to get the visual
of what this gentleman who worked as a
moderator at facebook reveals and talks
about
and is uncomfortable at the end himself
talking about this
i suggest if there's any video i
recommend you skip in this being the one
for you to skip with that being said
i've given you the warning
and i'm letting you know
it's going to be uncomfortable having
said that if you do stick around to
watch it
here's the interview
with sean spiegel
my guest today is sean spiegel who is a
former facebook moderator and we're
going to get down to the bottom of what
is going on at facebook but the life of
a moderator at facebook he was there for
about six or seven months
it's gonna give you hopefully a lot more
perspective on what happens on the back
end with that being said sean thank you
so much for being a guest on
valuetainment
thank you very much for having me today
so sean if if you don't mind let's just
start off with the basics for the
audience who doesn't know what is a
facebook moderator
what is the job of a facebook moderator
so the general job of a facebook
moderator is you are put into specific
cues as in specific types of content
and for a facebook moderator what you
are to do is you're to go through this
type of content that's given to you
and you're just supposed to go through
the policies you're supposed to action
it and if there's anything out of the
ordinary you would add some notes to it
and you would move on
so that would be what a general facebook
moderator does so so for is there levels
to moderators or no is there like you
know how your level one clearance level
two clearance level three is there
anything like that or no every moderator
same level
no no in fact there are different levels
it's not specifically levels like one
two three it's actually you're broken
down into different types of departments
uh for most people you would be in the
general queue that's just people that
have the basic knowledge of facebook
basic area of content what you're mostly
going to see there is just
general photos memes pictures nothing
that would be out of the ordinary
uh text messages instant messages just
everything that would be very benign
for me as an example i was actually
promoted to the graphic violence and
hate speech division
that is a division that actually
requires a whole different set of skills
and my title actually went from
moderator to social media content
analyst as i went through there got it
so my title there was social media
content analysts and what i did is i
specifically dealt with content that was
in the graphic violence so i dealt with
pictures photos videos
of basically the worst things that you
could do to a human or an animal
and i also dealt with a lot of hate
speech as well a lot that had to do in
and out of the united states
but to answer your question
the cues are generally regulated
depending on what your expertise is if
you have a degree in specific areas
you're able to focus on
but the largest queue the one that most
people are in would be the general queue
and that's where you'll just see the
most benign of content that's where most
content goes to
if you have a specialty in something if
you specialized in an area
you would go to some of these different
ones sexual exploitation sexual
solicitation drugs and firearms graphic
violence hate speech i could go on and
on
got it so uh
can you unpack
what some of the stuff you saw i mean
you know sometimes i sit there and i let
you say i'm going through my news feed
and i'll see a
mother or father beating a six month old
kid i'm like why is this thing here it's
got 52 million views i'm like this
what's the purpose of leaving this on or
you'll see some bizarre videos that make
zero sense for them to be on but they
have those things up there what did you
see and i can only imagine as a user
what that makes me feel when i walk away
what are some of the things you saw
i saw a lot
the best way to explain it is if you've
been to many of these sites i know some
of them are not around anymore but there
were sites such as um
best gore chaotic with a k there was the
live leaks
there were many other sites that i could
think of like hard candy
and you would have these uh videos
mainly of just these horrific acts that
could range from child pedophilia to
putting fireworks in a dog's mouth and
then them setting it up on fire
to um
fathers making their daughters have sex
with pigs and then
stabbing the pig
while the daughter was
having sex with the pig
um i saw
those types of videos day by day a lot
of these had to deal with bestiality
abuse against animals
um i also specialized in
during the summer it was in china the
dog eating festival so
the facebook allowed these different
types of videos and photos up there of
people that were cooking skinning eating
dogs alive
because facebook said that due to the
cultural differences it would be the
equivalent of us having pictures of cows
or chickens
so they allowed people to basically just
mutilate dogs on live stream
through video through photos
for the sake of this dog food festival
that they have in china every summer
so
you see that video you see the dog
eating festival in china what else was
there so so far it's sexual
exploitation animal
any other kind are you seeing also
killing are you seeing like live
shooting what else are some of the
things you guys understand uh there were
plenty of live shootings in fact a lot
of them came from the united states
having to do between gang wars people
that would um
just have their cell phones out in the
middle of a shootout
there would also be a lot of content
from the middle east of people that were
stoning pedophiles to death or people
that were basically just beating their
kids until they were black and blue on
the face and their eyes were popping out
of their head
a lot of the content that had to do with
the middle east usually had to deal with
beating women and children
or stoning people that they perceived as
doing a wrongdoing
there was in fact this one video that i
was working with content-wise
and it was a person going to put a gun
in another man's mouth and then pulled
the trigger
and you could visibly see the innards
going through the back of his skull
and i actioned it to delete it
and there was another person that like
checks the moderators checks the checker
so to speak
and this person made the claim that what
we saw was not actually the visible
innards going out but bullet fragments
and i made the argument that it's
clearly white these are skull fragments
coming out of the back of their head
they're not silver they're not bullet
holes
and this person actually said that i was
wrong
and that video was allowed to stay on
there because of that
so
a lot of a lot more of the content had
to deal with the sexual exploitation a
lot of it dealt with children that were
online and they were basically being
groomed by pedophiles to come meet them
in person
oh there was also an incident with organ
harvesting videos so a lot of these
children in other countries
were basically being ripped apart alive
and they were having their organs taken
out without screaming and i remember how
bad it was that day because everybody
had to come into the main area and calm
everybody down there were like
people that were throwing up on the
floor like people that were just
screaming and crying wait these are your
co-workers who are throwing up on the
floor yes and
i remember one of our team leads was
telling us how we were going to be
getting more
graphic content specifically because
facebook couldn't keep up with the
amount that they were getting
so they were telling us that like the
floodgates were opening so we were just
going to be dealing with graphic content
all the time in my department
so i got two questions let me go to the
one uh first
you know when
cops and cops are known for having a
very high divorce rate
because the life of a cop is not the
most glamorous life you know all we see
is you know what they're doing we see it
on tv good cops bad cups all this stuff
but they have a very high divorce rate
the life sucks from what many of my
friends talk to me about
a person who's a divorce attorney
you're
not gonna be able to have
uh you're constantly talking about
divorces and if you're married you're
gonna come home and all you're thinking
about is you're probably next because
your entire life is about divorces i was
being recruited to be a special forces
at the 18th delta fifth group at fort
campbell kentucky and they asked me to
go interview with other 18 deltas
and the guy was telling me he says you
ever planning on getting married and
falling in love i said of course he says
don't ever become special forces because
you can't you're psychologically going
to be off i'm like i'm cycling says
you're psychologically going to be out
that's going to mess with you that was
one interview then i went to the next
guy then the next guy the next guy
some jobs you take they're gonna mess
with you
but this is different there's a
difference between you watching
you know certain videos and certain
articles versus seeing this how are you
guys psychologically affected by this
when you're doing this eight hours a day
and you're going home how are you
handling that how's it affecting you
uh i was actually doing this ten hours a
day uh specifically because they needed
extra hands on deck for the extra two
hours to do this
so i was there always a bit longer than
most other people were specifically
because of the department i worked in
um just talking about the mental health
of the people that i worked with
it was not good within the building
so there were people that were smearing
feces on the bathroom walls there were
people that were
defecating in the sinks and the urinals
there were people that would just be
like
smoking drinking
in the middle of the day in their cars
during their break period
there was always talk about people using
the break room for sexual activities
there was always people that were
bringing in all sorts of illegal
substances to take while they were doing
this stuff
uh just the mental health of my
coworkers was not well because of all
this
specifically going through we were
supposed to have a counselor there some
mental health therapist to help
i was only able to see this person once
and it wasn't even the actual one that
worked there it was someone that was
just filling in
and i remember he flat out told me
i don't know how i can help you guys
because he did not know what to do he
did not see the type of content we were
seeing
and he just flat out said i'm filling in
but i don't know how to help you guys
because all of this was new to him as
well and i never met the actual person
that was supposed to be on board with us
every day
and a lot of my coworkers i spoke with
never met this person either
i'm not even sure if this person really
existed or maybe this person was only
there like a few hours a few days
so i have no real confirmation on this
person ever actually helping somebody
through a tough time they've had there
sean
um
uh are you guys talking to each other
uh are you guys on break you're like
dude you won't even believe what i just
saw today is it constant
hearing of like visually is this a
location near facebook headquarters are
you offside give me a
visual of what this looks like in the
relationship amongst each other so that
give me a little bit of the optics there
all right so this was not so this was
third party it was not facebook it was a
third-party vendor named cognizant
technology solutions
and so cognizant had a deal with
facebook that they were going to take a
part of their content
and they were going to work with it
off-site so they have their own sites
and we did have some people from
facebook stopped by occasionally to see
how everything was going i remember i
saw one of mark zuckerberg's personal
lawyers there once
um but for the most part this was while
we had the facebook tech to go do all
the stuff
and we had all facebook's content it was
managed directly by cognizant
and so going forward with that it was in
tampa florida
and it was in this place called woodland
center so it was just this kind of giant
parking lot kind of just in the middle
of nowhere
and it was just this small building that
had it there
and you walk into the building
they have um a security guard in front
of their all times
you're not allowed to bring any pen
paper pencils anything you could record
or like take any notes on not even your
phone so you can't have a phone on you
while you're working no you cannot have
your phone on you if they see you with
your phone they just immediately fire
you
and i'm dead serious they just they just
can you if they see the phone because
they're the way that they describe it is
all this is other people sensitive
content so they don't want anybody
recording taking notes anything which i
understood for like the phones but for
like pencil paper they didn't even allow
that in there
um so you go in there
and basically you have these two
incredibly small bathrooms that only
have about two toilets two urinals in
the mail bathroom and i believe just two
toilets in the girls bathroom
and this place housed about a thousand
people so it was terrible conditions for
the bathroom
and so you have these two small
bathrooms then you have this kitchen
area
and
it was just a very small cafeteria it
was just very vanilla there was nothing
really there
they did set up this little store there
and every week they would give you
twenty dollars on a card
and you could go eat uh whatever you
wanted to
as long as you didn't go over your
twenty dollars at this little store
but
for some reason all the food there was
junk food and sometimes they would have
like fruit cups salads but
all the people that were higher up got
all those so it's like the team leaders
the trainers they were able to get the
good food
and so everybody else was really just
eating junk food all day and what really
kind of hurt me a lot is i would see
this graphic content
and
what my people would tell me is like hey
go grab something there go cheer
yourself up so i grab like you know in
chocolate milk some donuts and
i put on a lot of weight while working
there i actually weighed over 300 pounds
when i left
i have lost about 41 pounds now since
then
um and i put on some good muscle i'm
very happy about that but um
it was a very unhealthy lifestyle just
not for me but for everybody that was
working there
so
after that you just have these two main
wings
and they are just filled with computers
there's no cubicles no nothing they say
that they wanted it all open
but
it was just nothing but computers
and there was nothing else there for us
they had this one tiny room in the back
corner
what was supposed to be like a calm down
relaxing room where it's like if you
need to calm down after seeing this
content you could go in there they had
like legos they had like a little
billiard board and all that but no one
was ever allowed in there
because they would like time you
obsessively if you ever got up from your
seat
so it would be like if you go to the
restroom they would literally put a
timer on your computer
and if it goes over the amount of time
you're going to get yelled at by the
boss for going over the time
if you're on a break and you're like a
minute late from your break
the computer alarm will go off and it's
immediately going to tell your
supervisor that you're not there
and even if you're just like right
around the corner you're going to get
another warning you're going to get you
know dock and pay
so they were very like
obsessive with you being at your
computer at all times
in fact what was just really ridiculous
with it
is how
there were people there that wanted to
just get up and walk after spending like
four hours doing nothing at the computer
and
like the bosses just would not have it
they just wanted to have a body in the
seat
they didn't really care how that body
was doing they just wanted the person in
the seat and that was it what were they
paying you guys
so they were paying us about thirty
thousand dollars um it was originally 28
working in the graphic violence division
per month
per month
i wish it was per year they're paying
you 30 grand a year
yes
to to watch all okay
okay they're paying you 30 a year and
that's like 15 bucks an hour is what
they're paying you okay
so so these are two separate companies
now let me ask you is the liability
is a liability on facebook or is the
liability on
cognizant technology solutions and
how is facebook holding these guys
accountable for doing their job right
uh so that's an easy question to answer
facebook is not holding them accountable
in fact it was cognizant that was the
one that backed out of the deal with
facebook about being a vendor for their
content
facebook was not holding them
accountable at all cognizant was able to
do whatever they wanted without really
any interference
as long as a certain amount of content
was being uh looked at every single day
that's all that they cared about
they really didn't even care much about
the accuracy ratings they just wanted
the number to go up to say we looked at
this much content
that was really what they were focusing
on what's successful what percentage is
successful to them
so a percentage that was successful them
is they wanted each and every employee
to do about 500 to 1 000 pieces of
content every day
and
i was usually doing about 100 to 200
contents on usually a day where there
was not much going on because
going through this content
when you're in a specialized area you
have to not only just action it you have
to go through the internet find out the
source of it if you can find it verify
if it's real or not make sure you have
the links make sure you you say how you
found it and then write up a report on
it
so a great example would be like i'm
finding a lot of these terrible
bestiality videos and i was able to find
a bestiality website and i was able to
find those same videos from there so i
was able to find the source of it there
so then i would write up a report saying
that this was not an original facebook
piece of content this was something that
was taken from another website and then
i would write up my report saying why it
would be taken down
what the actions would be what it breaks
in the policy so that does take up a
good amount of time especially when
you're basically going through the whole
internet looking for a piece of content
like that
but there were a lot of times when my
trainers would tell me
go slow do it you're doing great that's
why we promoted you and then i would
have the team leader telling me no you
need more content more content more
content done
and so i was getting two different
perspectives on what i needed to do
there there was one that was telling me
i needed bigger number
of content and then i had another
group of people telling me that i needed
to just focus on the accuracy of what i
was doing because these were real people
real animals in these situations
it was really pretty much the ethical
side versus the business side i'm
looking at this tampa bay times article
that says facebook agrees to pay 52
million dollars settlement with content
moderators who suffer trauma on the job
former and current moderators in florida
and across the country will receive a
thousand dollars each and may be
eligible for more money to cover medical
treatments and damages etc etc uh uh
is this did you see this actually become
a reality like did you guys see payment
from facebook on this 52 million uh no i
believe it's still in court right now
still actually being worked on um casey
newton from the verge uh told me that he
wanted me to be a part of it
and so i decided i will be i originally
didn't want to because i didn't want
anybody to come across thinking that i'm
just doing like coming out and saying
all this stuff
like there's a message i wanted to bring
about this
but um i decided that it probably would
be best especially after everything
that's happened to me
and then there's another article that
says a total of 556 employees will be
laid off early next year from a
controversial facility near carrollwood
that monitors facebook for banned
content such as hate speech bullying
threats and videos of violence against
criminals and children
violence against animals and children
cognizant technology solution a
contractor
for facebook plans to close its
operations at 7725
woodland center boulevard about two
miles north of tampa bay tampa
international airport is that the
facility you were at the center this is
the facility crazy so so you you
remember when this story came out
because this is two years ago a year and
a half ago give or take
i do remember that story coming out
so they so you said
cognizant technology solutions dropped
facebook
yes why did they drop facebook if it's
an account that's paying you good money
i believe it was just the bad amount of
publicity that they were getting i got
last i heard about it is their stocks
were starting to drop and there was a
lot of negative news going on about how
they were being how they were treating
everybody by being a vendor for facebook
so
they decided just to drop the account
all together is this the same cognizant
company that's a publicly traded company
doing like 16 billion a year like doing
uh uh revenue is
yeah 16.65 and 20 is this the company
like that's the company yes got it
interesting so i'm sure they don't want
that kind of publicity to be tied to
that is that is that their business
model though like do they do this also
for twitter youtube facebook linkedin
other sites as well or was this like a
singular project that they took with
facebook
as what i was specifically told is that
it was not in florida but it was in
texas
there was another branch of cognizant
that was doing the same thing we were
doing but instead of facebook instagram
it was twitter
so they were doing this for twitter as
well okay right right because it looks
like i'm looking at the reputation this
company doesn't have a bad reputation it
just seems like this one account they
were taking i don't know maybe there is
it looks like a
reasonable company that does good things
and
they decided to cut this relationship so
let me go a little deeper with this so
one you explained what it was like for
you guys i can only imagine how
challenging it could be
and you were explaining the fact that
fetus on the bathroom wall and you know
in the in the stalls where you wash your
hands and you said sex in the bathroom
what what's that all about what has that
got to do with anything is it who they
were hiring were they pretty much hiring
anybody and everybody off the street or
was there a requirement to meet
to have the job to work here
so
there was an initial test that you take
for the interview where it goes through
how well you're familiar with facebook
and instagram and then after that they
show you a book and they say this is
going to be some of the content you
might see
and they say you might see it
and the content was very benign compared
to what was actually there they showed
um hentai which is like the animation
pornography drawings
so they showed some of that
they showed some memes like that had to
deal with um like if you had like
pineapple on your pizza you would die
or it was just the incredibly benign
things like that there was nothing that
was like overly bad the biggest thing
that they showed in that book and it was
a picture that cnn took uh this little
boy
and i believe he was taken from the
middle east on a plane and he was all
bloodied up and uh he was all dusty and
they showed us that
they said this might be the worst it
gets and i was like i remember that
picture by the way
right and so that that was as far as
they showed us saying like this is going
to be the type of content you'll see so
of course i'm thinking if that's the
worst i can do this right
uh in retrospect i do believe that they
were just hiring bodies to fill the
seats i do not think that they were
hiring the best people
i think they seemed like they were
fortunate that they had someone like me
that had a college degree that had
background in going into public records
that was able to do the stuff they
wanted me to do
because a lot of my job at the graphic
violence division was to go through
content and if it was
um if it was in the united states
i would go through the accounts i would
go through their linkedin their facebook
twitter anything any sort of public
accounts
i would go look at any information look
at their property records housing
records go through any sort of utility
bills that i could find
and i would basically write a portfolio
of them
and i did this a lot in college when i
took public affairs reporting so i was
very familiar how to like find public
records go through these areas and do
this yeah so that's was one reason why
they wanted me on the graphic violence
division was because i had a good bit of
knowledge on how to basically find out
how they put it find the uh the bad spot
on the apple
so so so you start off as the the people
at the bottom is general q
with just meme stuff like that comes up
you get a promotion you become a social
media content analyst
and you start seeing stuff that just
makes no sense
walk me through the hierarchy structure
who's after you who's after that person
who's after that person what does that
tree look like so it's not really like a
tree it's more just like the general
queue is at the bottom and what you
specialize in would just be all a big
circle that is above the general cube so
it's not
so much that there was anybody like
another department that was above me
it was very much just different
departments that focused on different
types of content at that
and they only and those departments were
very small
so in my department it was me and seven
other people
and we were we were the whole graphic
violence and hate speech division
they had one that was for bullying that
had just 10 people on it
they had one for drugs and firearms
and that one just had about five people
on it so
it wasn't like a lot of people were
being put into these different areas the
vast majority were just put in general
queue
and if you showed any sort of promise
they would put you on a different desk
got it
got it so so you said something earlier
you said uh
uh when you saw this video with the guys
shooting the guy's brains out
and you said it was obviously white and
like no that's not that's the gun it's
not real and it was left to stay on
who allowed it to who was approving it
above you was it a facebook person or
was it a cognitive technology solution
person it was a facebook person oh
that's a facebook person so it goes
through you
you kind of mark it up and then it
leaves cognizant technology solution to
facebook
and a facebook person dictates whether
they're going to leave that alone or not
correct
so so okay so when that happens
is like that video that took place where
they left it on did they leave it on in
specific countries or they did they
leave it on across the board anywhere
america all of that or did they filter
america out because that's the one place
they didn't want to leave on they left
it on everywhere all countries and the
specific reason for that is because
facebook has hyper-specific
types of policies
and for graphic violence what they say
is
videos
that are not in a medical setting and
you can see visible innards are not
allowed
and so according to this this was a
video
this was not in a medical setting
but they claimed that the skull
fragments and the bit of brain matter
that came out was not visible innards so
they said it could stay on and so they
allowed it
that was their reasoning behind it
okay
uh what other videos that obviously made
no sense to stay on they would leave it
on what other videos did you see where
you're like okay there's like for
example the pick video you talked about
did that one get taken down
so that one did get taken down but it
got taken down specifically because that
was not
one that was in the general
uh area of where we get our content from
that one was in a private facebook page
and this was what i really specialized
in was that there were a lot of private
pages and they would be named something
like i love dogs or
let's go bulldogs or anything like that
and so you would just see it it would be
like a very general name you wouldn't
think anything bad about it and it was a
private only page so you could only go
to that page if you were invited
so if you were actually invited
i guess you then realized that it was
actually just a cesspool of specialized
content that was horrific and disgusting
and what made it the worst is that
these videos and these private pages
they were homemade they were not from
other websites there were people that
were making this these videos
and they were inviting people into the
page to buy and auction the videos
so what
the hardest part about that was
is that they were using the facebook
payment system
they were using other means of getting
currency
and they would have a horrific video
such as the video of the pig and the
girl
and people would actually bet an auction
on how much
how much money so they could get the
full video
and then that person that made the
original video
would also take requests from others and
make content specialized to taylor
tailored to them
so that's that's what i dealt with and a
lot of these this type of content that
was homemade by the parents by the
children by the people
that were making money off of it
this was stuff that was just in the
private area of these private pages
and facebook would not allow me to do
anything about it because even if i
wrote the report even if i could prove
that they were in america even if i had
their driver's license their face their
license plate their home address
they said that it would
they said that it would look bad for
them and they said that an internal
facebook team would look at it
and yet that same content was still on
there
so are you saying if they really wanted
to catch the bad guy they could
but because they could figure out where
it's coming from is that kind of what
you're saying
yes and
i figured out where a lot of the content
was coming from and so did my co-workers
that worked with me on the job so it
wasn't hard for you to figure that out
it was not because people put their
names on their content they will
actually like like make it a brand they
will be stupid enough to show their
house their home address they are stupid
enough
to have their car license plate show up
in the video they are dumb enough to say
their first and last name even though
this is a homemade video you can easily
send this to the fbi
but
facebook didn't want to do that why is
it because they don't want
uh the users to feel uncomfortable that
the information is being shared with a
third party is that kind of what their
alibi was
no in fact their alibi was that
they were saying that this content going
public would be bad for facebook's
optics so they would just have an
internal investigation through it
through facebook's own team and
obviously that went nowhere when you
would see the same profiles the same
pictures making the same content
back the next day nothing ever happened
to them and they're making new content
to go with it
um okay so let's let's go a little bit
uh let's go a little bit deeper with
this so
simple why uh david why do they want uh
uh why do they want the stuff to stay on
like what's the purpose of staying on so
let me kind of give you my skeptical
side and you tell me
if i'm on or if i'm off so on one end i
sit there and i give them the benefit of
the doubt they have so much content
that's coming in
they just can't track all of it it's
it's like they can't even track all of
it for the billions of postings that's
taking place
so eventually they're just kind of like
you know what uh man we can't get to
everything so you know the whole 98
ratio or the 80 ratio whatever they got
okay so that's that the next part they
put it in there and they don't take it
down because they don't think fully it's
inappropriate and they have an excuse or
reason to say this makes sense to stay
up or the next one is
it still drives so much traffic and
eyeballs that indirectly it's helping
the algorithms to help them stay number
two website in the world
and that helps with business i don't
know i'm trying to figure out what the
reason would be to leave this stuff up
the reason that i can say for leaving
the stuff up is that facebook in general
has been staying stagnant in the amount
of baller and the amount of people that
sign up for it
and it's also been declining in the
amount of new users that have been going
on it so i think maybe part one would be
facebook is incredibly desperate to keep
its own demographic that it has no
matter how obscene and disgusting and
perverted it is
number two i think facebook would rather
very much just um
put all this under the rug
not even deal with it
not do anything with it just say we're
gonna do it categorize it file it but
never actually act on it
and i completely believe that facebook
is too much of a coward
to actually go after these people that
are putting posting this content on
their own website
in fact i think facebook is
more concerned with hiding it as best as
they can and just pretend it never
happened
okay so we didn't see it oh we didn't
see it
but you get a million people you know
how you go uh online and you see a video
and you say report report report report
report
does that go to an organization like the
one you guys were part of like what does
a report
action do to content
that one sees i'm sure plenty of videos
that you see that's like this is just
not appropriate to be on here when one
clicks report where does that go so
normally when you click report it would
go into the general queue once it's in
the general queue it will either be
categorized based on what you see in it
and then it would be taken off into the
different other queues
so that's basically how it works for the
most part just with that
uh the report button in my opinion only
really works for the general queue
because when you deal with these higher
up more dangerous things types of
content that you're dealing with
uh the report button really becomes very
banal and in a sense that it's just not
useful
and the main part of what's happening is
it's really more of an ai that's then
scanning things to see if it looks
similar to what you're looking at
and then it will send it forward uh but
the report button is really just there
if i had to be honest for things that
are such as like bullying or like
something that you just don't agree with
and that's eat speech-wise
um
the way i got the vast majority of my
content was specifically through digging
through these private pages
and what the ai was sending me because i
was working with an ai that was trying
to help identify graphic content
so i a lot of what i got was not based
on the report button
because the vast the pub the general
public was not seeing what i was seeing
because these are all private pages so
these are not things that would go viral
and the only time the fbi the police or
like facebook really got involved is
when one of those videos broke out of
those private pages and then it got
mainstream there was an instance i
remember specifically of um
these two girls and they were
babysitting these kids and they were
forcing the toddlers and babies to smoke
marijuana and that one went
viral and i remember facebook came in
with their team we actually had the
local police from that area work with us
and we were able to identify them and
apprehend those two
so that would be one of those rare
instances where we actually did do
something
but it only really happened because it
went mainstream because it went viral
and a lot of the content i dealt with
just never became viral because it was
in these isolated pockets
uh just
to go on a little bit more about that
with um a lot of this content especially
the graphic violence stuff
facebook had this incredibly weird
policy where
a lot of abuse whether towards children
animals adults
they would leave it on there
and they would tell us they would leave
it on there because they would say that
either a good samaritan or a police
officer would see that content
and they would like
give a lead to who that person was
and so their idea was we're just going
to leave it on there so
hopefully a good samaritan will give us
some info and then they can get justice
to them what do you think about that
it's a lie because the police don't have
our systems
the police aren't looking at what we're
looking at they don't have they don't
have the software that facebook has to
actually look at the type of content
that we're looking at
and i wish
i realized that when i was in training
instead of believing it and thinking
that i was making
a change and trying to like help these
people and animals even if they're
already dead as long as like their final
moments aren't being desecrated in these
videos and pictures
and i really did believe that
somehow good samaritans or police were
actually going to help
see this content report on it say who it
was in there
but those people aren't seeing it
only i'm seeing it
so so let me ask you so
sometimes when you run a big company
you
don't really know
what's going on everywhere right i mean
uh uh so you know facebook's got give or
take 60 000 employees that's a pretty
big organization they got some sites say
they get 1.87 billion unique visitors
per month some sites say they get two
and a half
to 2.8 billion unique visitors per month
users per month okay whatever the number
is let's say two billion that's a lot of
people that come to their website on a
monthly basis
so you got 60 000 plus employees you got
two billion users actively that are
logging on to your website you're you're
the largest country in the world
essentially china's got one and a half
billion india's got 1.4 1.5 billion you
got 2 billion you're a country you're a
virtual government
do you think this stuff is stuff that
maybe
it's so far away from zuck's hands that
he doesn't even know this this stuff is
taking place
no he knows what's taking place because
his hands are all in it like this is his
creation and as we've seen through his
multiple appearances with congress and
the way he speaks in any sort of
interviews he obviously presents himself
presents himself as someone that has his
hands and all the all the pies so to
speak
um what i think is the problem is one he
facebook has grown too big and needs to
be cut down into sizable chunks maybe
they need to be operated by different
individuals that are not affiliated with
him
but the biggest problem i had was just
the reallocation of resources was
terrible there was so i talked a little
bit about this ai that we were using
that was trying to help with graphic
content
what the i ai was primarily being used
for was looking at sexually suggestive
photos not even photos that were sexual
not even photos that showed anything
it wasn't any pornographic images
so examples like if there's a picture of
a girl and she has her butt sticking out
in the photo she's wearing all clothes
the the ai needed to know if that was a
butt focus picture or not or
a lot of the times we would just look at
the pictures and we would just identify
if something was cleavage as in the
indentation between the breasts that was
cleavage there was another one of
identifying women in swimsuits
there was another one that identified
nipple
or areola so we actually had to train
the ai to look at something and see if
they could just identify the areola
around the nipple
so this is what a lot of the ai
resources were going to not graphic
violence not child pornography
not any of these terrible things it was
going towards these
sexually suggestive photos and videos
and it was just a terrible use of the ai
there was absolutely no need to teach an
ai how to categorize that content
because
none of that content was breaking any
policy
because even though we were working with
it we were never actioning that content
because there was nothing ever wrong
with the content for some reason they
just wanted that categorized
it was ridiculous that they decided to
put the ai to use that way so so let me
let me go a different direction here so
we you know uh uh throw alex jones in
there throw
uh whoever what
you know any of these other guys that
are out there throw trump in there throw
some of these guys that are you know
banned from facebook and they're not on
facebook and first they took alex
jones's company down they took him down
right how different do they treat
threats of people that share ideas that
they may not agree with whether as
outlandish of an idea as it is as
communism
or you know anarchy or whatever it is as
outlandish as it may be
how do they process that
versus
the child porn and all the other stuff
that they leave on there in their mind
why do they think this is more
threatening
than
the child porn content
so
they deal with the politics more than
any of the other content i discussed
about specifically because politics are
a major part of u.s life and
facebook takes place in the united
states so facebook has feels like it has
this priority to take a look at politics
over anything else first
and
when i worked there
there were some instances with justice
kavanaugh when he was having his
confirmation and then there was dr ford
who claimed uh sexual
molestation at a younger age
um so
that was one of those rare times that
all of facebook all of the fbi got
really involved
because throughout that entire hearing
process there were people that were on
the trump side that were saying that
they wanted to put like pipe bombs
underneath dr ford's car
and then there was this other side that
they wanted to ram cars into justice
kavanaugh if they if they saw him and
they were each like creating their own
little terrorist
cell deciding on which on who to kill
who to take out for their political
ambition
and i guess if i just had to go more
straightforward with it
while the stuff going on is horrendous
and terrible and it should be given
absolute priority a lot of the content i
dealt with should be given the priority
unfortunately
it seems like the politics and the
extremism on both sides and yes i'm
gonna say both sides because what i
witnessed on facebook the people on the
left side
were just as crazy as the people on the
right side
a lot of that stuff has been bleeding
into real world life
and it hasn't just been staying on
facebook or on the internet and it's
been actually
being brought into real life actions and
consequences and so i think facebook
has maybe thought that that's a bigger
deal of having these things come
these things be more straightforward
especially when a lot of these people
are frequent users on their sites and
when they get public headlines that
looks bad for them
so you said on the on the right side you
said the bombs ford all that what and
you said it's crazy on the left side and
the right side
what crazy things did you see on the
left side
so for the left side there was
there was much talk about how a lot of
conservative women should have their
genitals mutilated because they were
claiming that these conservative women
didn't deserve to be women for that
reason because they're not going with
the feminist side
uh there was also a lot going on towards
the gay rights where they were saying
that they wanted to indoctrinate kids as
early as two or three into
gay rights act activist group which
i am a person that stands for gay rights
but i'm not a person that would ever
like go that forward to someone that's
just a young child
there was also much talk of grooming
young children into being drag queens
and there was also much talk going
forward about
how basically they wanted to start
segregating democrats and republicans or
primarily democrats and trump supporters
and wanting to like slash the tires of
their cars or like
deface their housing or threaten them in
public and there was a lot of these
actions that were starting to become
real world consequences
and so as i said there are
plenty of crazies on the left side
that uh we're creating real real world
harm
now what access did you have and earlier
under the messaging you said
the general key was photo memes
text messages instant messenger
so you guys were able to see what's
being said in the instant messenger and
text messages or no
yes also whatever we post there and
we're communicating you see all of it
yes absolutely
[Laughter]
everything that's communicated here if
you wanted to see all of it you can
easily see it yes and
you have access to who like
do is there levels of clearance on who
you have access to want to be able to go
see let me see if this one guy i don't
like let me see what he stands for i'm
gonna go see what this guy's saying to
this person here could you do that or
was there limitations to what they sent
to you
no
uh in the general queue there were
limitations where i was there were not
were you ever tempted to see some
conversations of people that were higher
ups or no
i was tempted yes but not specifically
higher ups uh i have to be honest
politics isn't my thing i was more
curious about seeing what my cousin was
saying up in georgia
but um
if i have to be honest imagine like my
cousin doesn't like me
i i'm not a political person even though
when i was in cognizant
it was very political in there
but i'm just not much of a politics
person to begin with and and you know
what's the unique thing about talking to
you you're very sincere you're just like
this is this is who i am this is what
i'm doing
were you again i don't even know like
what what do you know about shadow
banning that we don't know about you
know like you know when you
see sometimes you create content and all
of a sudden you're like wait a minute
like you'll see videos that are momentum
momentum momentum
and typically when a video's momentum
goes away it's typically a drop off like
this
right and it goes away it's just kind of
how it works i mean i've been doing this
for a long time we got a few billion
views total online
but sometimes you would see video goes
like this like this like this and then
sometimes it just goes boom
that's not possible for a video to do
that there's got to be something that
automatically brings it down 90 within a
second
what is shadow banning something that's
a real thing that's taking place and
who behind closed doors is moderating
who they don't want to get exposure and
who they want to get exposure
so the whole process about shadow
banning is what they're trying to do is
content that they feel is either
offensive controversial or any sort of
content that is just um they feel like
will cause real world harm
they will tend to try to stop it before
it becomes too viral so they don't want
it to become a viral message they don't
want it to go mainstream so they usually
just try to cut it off right at that
tipping point right before it would
become viral or mainstream
uh the people that
focus on that type of content were not
incognizant they were with the facebook
queue in general they were the ones that
actually worked with facebook itself
um but for shadow banning as i said
before it was very much that they were
just trying to cut off things that were
trying to almost on the verge of being
viral
there were things that could have that
could range from hate speech
there were things that could range from
political
ideology they could range from things
that could be misinformation about
medical uses medical diagnostics
i mean i'm sure a lot of people have
seen everything go along with the kova
19 response and how facebook has been
working with that
um so it's just things that
are going and they're on the verge of
being viral but they have not quite made
it yet they just kind of cut it off
right then and there before it gets to
that point
did you see the article that came out a
couple weeks ago saying the fact that
facebook has an elite group of users i
think it's like five to six million
people
that no matter what they say no matter
what they put in the article talked
about how neymar
had a picture of
some girl that was trying to sue him and
he put a picture of her naked or
something like that i don't know the
exact story so um here i'm gonna put my
little plug in here for another thing um
the wall street journal has a podcast
and they're doing the facebook files
and so
that's where i heard that story from yes
it was like some brazilian baseball
player he was very popular in that
country
but yes so apparently according to these
facebook documents there is this large
group of people
and it's not even so much that they're
big shot celebrities they can just be
joe blows as long as the people in
facebook
add them to the list
and these people just get immunity from
almost everything and i thought what was
very interesting is that donald trump
was included into that elite group of
people that nothing bad could happen to
him
uh but apparently he was in that group
trump wasn't at five to six million yes
huh interesting
go ahead you were saying something but
apparently
i just found that very interesting that
he was part of that group
and then everything after january 6 he
was taken out of that group out of fear
of real world retaliation after what
happened at the
capitol
sean let me ask you how much since you
were in this for like seven months
you know sometimes you have a bad
experience with a company or something
personal that happens to you whether
it's
you know
testing with a drug you take a drug and
next thing you know
your family member gets addicted to
vicodin they can't get off a vicodin and
and they harm themselves so for the rest
of your life all you're doing is
studying
vicodin right and doing whatever you can
because you're just like obsessed to get
to the bottom of it to see what really
happens sometimes
in military and accidental somebody dies
or there's a suicide and all these other
things that happen you commit your life
to wanting to know more about it did
this kind of get you to say you know
what i want to kind of get to the bottom
and see what the hell is going on over
here kind of like i don't want to have
anything to do with this i'm moving on
in my life
uh so i just want to say that
there's no sort of revenge scheme i have
against facebook i'm just one little
person i'm not here that
like if i was trying to go after
facebook i would definitely have tried
to go on like
oprah or many other different shows and
try to like say my story
for one i don't really want to be famous
known as hey you're the guy that watched
fetuses be smashed with hammers for 10
hours every day six days a week like
that's not really what i want to be
known for
um the reason that i'm doing this
and i speak out is because
when i
started working with
facebook i thought that the least i
could do
is try to help the people and animals
whose last moments were being desecrated
even if it's on video or picture
people that were mocking it making fun
of it getting off to it with sexual
pleasure
i wanted to at least
help these animals and people and their
dying moments
and at least give them closure
that's all i wanted to do is try to help
and they even kind of sold it to us when
we first started with training is that
you're going to be the police of
facebook
you're going to be policing it
monitoring it you're going to make it a
safer place
and i really bought into that
i it's i want to
i wish i could you know wash my hands of
it all and just go
i don't care anymore i don't want to
hear it anymore
but there was
there was too much
that happened on facebook that
should not
have ever been allowed
and i would probably put money on it
those same people are still making that
same content
one thing that really got to me
and this happened um
last year
and it was this woman that works
that was an activist
and she was telling me that she was
going
uh to congress to talk about these
specific things
so we talked a couple times and last
year she called me
and she said did you work
on these specific types of things in
texas and it was about these girls that
were being
held
in their parents basement and being used
as like sex toys and prostitutes
i said yes i did work on that
apparently
the authorities
just found out at that time and arrested
them
that was two years after i left facebook
and i wrote the report on that
and i did my best to make sure the
authorities would try to get it make
sure facebook would take it seriously
but facebook wouldn't let it get out
and so those girls suffered for two
extra years
and
there were many other cases similar to
that
and they wanted me to confirm that
it was that i actually sent a report in
and discussed that stuff
and
just makes me mad that they suffered two
extra years because facebook couldn't
even
do the right thing
and let the authorities know what it was
there was
another instance and it was one of the
first things i saw
and it was these two boys
and they grabbed an iguana by the tail
and they smashed the iguana onto the
pavement
and the iguana was just screaming
i've never heard an iguana scream and i
don't think most people have
and they kept doing it and doing it and
smashing the iguana onto the pavement
until it was just a bloody
pulp with a tail
and apparently those boys had their own
private facebook page
where they were bashing other animals to
death as well
and they never took it down that iguana
video was still up
and they were making more videos
of more animals they were killing
and they were getting paid for it
that's why i want to get this message
out is because
people are
suffering and nobody's doing anything
about it
and you may think that it's all just on
a different screen
it's not real they want you to sensitize
to it
but people are actually making money off
this thing and i think that's the most
disgusting thing in the world
is that people are getting paid and
there are people that want to pay you
to make this content
and that's why i do this and yes i would
like to get the bottom of this i would
like to know more about
what the heck they're doing in there
for somebody
you know
for somebody who's on the inside
sean who this is your world
what what can facebook do meaning
is it in their control to be able to
address this and stop it that's one so
let's just say the answer is yes if the
answer is yes
what can they do they've been talking
about ai for a long time
uh
you know from your perspective and and
again sean i appreciate you for sharing
that and it's 100 felt from speaking to
you it's very obvious that
you're not doing this for a dollar
you're doing this because you know
animals and people matter to you even
when you said earlier i'm not a politics
guy i don't follow politics i don't know
what's going on with politics but it's
not my world but what would you say
what would you say you know on what they
can do to eliminate all of this is it ai
is it internal team is it
what do you think that is
so
the the first thing that they truly need
to do
is if facebook
really wants to make this change is
zuckerberg has to step down because
zuckerberg is kind of
he's the one in the way of all this he's
the one that makes all decisions
he's the one that signs off on
everything and
this is zuckerberg's creation
so
if we had someone that was not him in
control then perhaps we could actually
get something done because i have i
don't see zuckerberg ever bending the
the knees so to speak to actually make
these changes
what i think needs to be changed could
be
facebook needs to be divided up into
different segments
and then have these different
independent individuals actually be in
charge of these segments
maybe we really do need some sort of
government influence uh looking into
this i know a lot of people will claim
that that would be like an oversight of
the american government
but when something has grown this big
and it has such uh
an importance in not just our society
but world society maybe it needs to not
be a private company and maybe it should
be some sort of public entity
i mean facebook
is so big along with other social media
sites that
maybe we shouldn't consider it a private
company maybe we should consider it as
something as a public square maybe it
should be considered something that
would be the equivalent of going out in
public and saying something and not
something that is controlled by a
private entity
um the only other thing i could possibly
think of facebook to do is maybe
facebook just needs to do a total revamp
of their policies
because when i was working there even
though the policies were changing by the
day they were only changing by specific
current events and they would only
change for like specific people
so like a great example would be um
during the justice kavanaugh hearings
i'll use that example again um
normally you're not allowed to make any
sort of disparaging bullying comments
about people that claim that they are
survivors of rape or molestation or
anything like that
but facebook made an exception with dr
ford so you were actually allowed to
make fun of her for that
oh i i apologize
okay um
and they made an exception you were
saying they made an exception for dr
ford
yes so so everybody could make fun of
her everybody could like claim that she
was asking for it she was a [ __ ] she was
a [ __ ] they could claim that
and for normal cases you're not because
it would get deleted
um but those were like the examples of
like policies changing for specific
people or specific events
and their policies were so hyper
specific i think
in a normal ruling body we could all
agree that
you know
killing killing animals online
should be banned i don't think there's
any reason why we should have it on
there
but apparently there's still like a lot
of stipulations like you can kill
animals on
video as long as it's in like an eating
preparing food setting
or you can also kill animals if it's in
a perceived self-defense setting where
there's a lot of people that took
advantage of those and they just like
mutilated a bear because they claimed
that they were hunting a bear in
self-defense
and so they had a caption that said like
killing that said like you know we're
killing the bear in self-defense and
they were like ripping its jaw off and
like just torturing the thing while it
was still alive and drugged up and
facebook allowed that because the
caption said oh it was in self-defense
so of course we can allow that
so it's just like these policies are
just
they're so easy to find loopholes on
crazy thing i'm going to throw out there
tell me what you think about this do you
think do you think there's any chance
that
maybe a a uh
uh
a
lar you know a country like china
has
additional motives on the inside where
they want to
hurt
this great country of america and they
want to figure out a way to internally
destroy the younger generation you know
any do you think china has any influence
over facebook
it's hard to say if i had to be honest i
i can't give a yes or no answer on that
i respect that
i respect that
uh you know sometimes you read articles
and it says
the hands a country like china has on
these major social media companies and
the other part is typically when you see
one person gets off on a site everybody
else follows suit do you think there is
a coalition amongst all the major social
media sites where they work together
where if one bans somebody the other
follows as well
yes yes but only when it's people that
are in higher up positions so if it's
just like regular joe guy i they're not
going to do that but if it's someone
that is more influential like as you
said alex jones before of course they're
gonna follow suit on that of course they
did the same thing with donald trump if
it was
a different sort of celebrity i'm sure
that they would have all gotten together
and gone like yeah let's all do a joint
ban on them that makes sense do you
think trump should have been banned or
alex jones should have been banned
uh
so that one's a difficult question
because i if i understand correctly
alex jones was the man who uh claimed
that the sandy hook shooting was a false
flag and that
the kids that died in that were actually
not killed and they're still alive
somewhere and the parents are lying
so
alex jones
i don't know his specifics of everything
he said has he claimed uh has he claimed
any sort of real world harm against
anybody has he personally
has has any of his uh posts anything
have they claimed any real world harm
like has he like claimed that he would
like do something to someone any
specific groups has he been antagonizing
like a specific uh demographic of people
i i couldn't uh verify that
so
that one i would honestly have to look
up because
guess what the internet is made for
conspiracy theories it's made for the
crazies i mean that's what the internet
is go to any website you'll find that
anywhere even wikipedia i mean i'm not
dissing wikipedia i just mean it's
that's the internet the internet was
made for insane theories that's just
what it is uh
but regarding donald trump uh
so what happened at the capitol was
incredibly weird
i personally do think that he riled up
his fans to go do that
i don't really know if there was an
ulterior motive to it but i do know that
he i would consider him to be the one
that you know
lit the match so to speak
but
i
you see these these are tough questions
because i don't want to come on here
thinking that i'm like politically
motivated one way or another so i i'm
trying not to come off that way
um but i guess just for the most part
it's really tough
because from an ethical standpoint you
could make that argument that it's a
public forum
he did say everybody to go home
afterwards he did he actually did make
that post i remember seeing that where
he said like everybody go home we love
you
um
i understand that
and i understand just uh he had broken
other policies before
there was but as a public figure
especially the president of the united
states it's really difficult to say like
if you're allowed to break it if we
treat him like a normal person if he did
not have the check mark next to his
twitter account
yes he should have been banned
because as a normal person he was
breaking the rules in the policies
but since he was the president of the
united states i feel like the social
media company should have had more of a
sit down with him
and say if you're going to do diplomacy
through social media
we need to set something up that can
actually make that happen
maybe social media needs to
grow
and figure out how to do diplomacy
through twitter
maybe that is an idea that we think is
really stupid
but it also should be something that
maybe we should actually think about
maybe it could be realistic in the
future
because if you're doing it through
social media and twitter at least you're
like speaking to the public and actually
getting your point across
so everybody knows where you stand
it's a it's a very difficult subject i
mean if i said yes he should be banned
there's more to it than that and if i
said no he shouldn't be banned there's
more to it these are subjects that
require
more than just a yes or no answer
is your birthday's are you september or
october baby
what month are you
june believe it or not i'm actually june
13th
so i'm actually like i think
a day before after trump's day
but the way your your your reasoning and
the way you're going very very
interesting
do you think most of these moderators
are politically motivated or no like are
some of them yes i'll just say yes
because that's all i heard that's all i
heard when i worked there
there were so many people that were of
different
political backgrounds i had many people
that were hard democrats that hated
anything a trump supporter said and they
delete it
and then on the other end i heard people
that were hardcore trump supporters and
they were just like i hate libtards i
want to get rid of this stuff
so
i heard it and there were there was
constantly bickering and fighting in
between there
and i can say for a fact that uh some of
the team leads i worked under they were
politically motivated because they would
flat out tell us their thoughts
so yes the moderators i did work with
were politically motivated
sean i got to tell you i uh
i've really enjoyed talking to you i
haven't enjoyed the stories like to
visually for my mind to go there and you
know it's extremely disturbing
but your approach on
you having the courage to go out there
and talk about this where you're getting
the audience to be thinking about these
issues issues
uh that are day-to-day on a platform
that we all use on a daily basis all of
us are on facebook instagram twitter
youtube it's part of our daily lifestyle
it's what 30 years ago somebody would go
home and they would turn on the tv to
watch
something today people turn on their
phones to look at what's going on
and
you uh
you seem very sincere there was nothing
that felt like there was a motivation
there for you on one side or the other
you're just kind of being a matter of
fact and sharing your
uh uh thoughts on this and i appreciate
that i'll give the final thoughts to you
if you want to say anything uh final to
the viewer i'll leave it up to you thank
you thank you um for all those that are
watching thank you very much for tuning
in and hearing my story out
if
i could get any sort of message across
it would be that
going forward with social media
we need to be more careful with
how we go about it we need to be more
careful on how we interact through
social media
we need to be more careful about how
we treat others through social media
and finally the biggest point i wanted
to get across about this is
facebook has this horrible content that
i have spoken about
with animals people babies toddlers
women children
and facebook refuses to take action on
it
and for anyone that's listening that has
any sort of anger from this like i do
please
let's try to stop this
because the last thing that we want is
for
more of this violence to happen on there
and more people make money off of
animals and people suffering
thank you sean appreciate your time
buddy thank you so much
all right thank you very much for having
me on again anytime anytime thank you
and by the way just had a curiosity what
are you thinking about what you just
heard right now very the messaging like
yeah we can check your messages
and then the one-sided with moderators
their job how it's on the outside how
they reported what stays just because
it's a private group
what are you thinking right now what's
your biggest take on i want to hear your
thoughts comment below
and if you
were enlightened by this interview
there's two other videos i think you'll
like one of them is one i did with
cambridge analytica britney kaiser who's
a whistleblower and i sat down and
talked about it click over that click
here to uh watch that interview and the
other one is what john mack if you have
to say about social media and his level
of trust for
social media cell phones he took a
different angle and he's not here with
us but this is an interview i did with
him four or five years ago if you've not
seen it click over here to watch that as
well take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you